finally a little bit of good news about
the UK economy let me just explain this
is showing you gross domestic product
the rate at which our income across the
country is growing or Contracting over
the last few quarters anything above the
line shows that increases anything below
the line that's contraction and famously
two successive quarters these are
quarters here these big bars of
contraction means a recession where are
we at the moment we're back in Q3 so the
third quarter of last year the economy
contracted by look you can see it there
0.3 if it was to go down again that
would mean we are technically in
recession and here's where the latest
data comes in because we also get
monthly numbers those big bars are
quarters the small bars are months and
look on the right hand side there we've
had two months so far of that final
quarter of last year and actually
they've both been positive that 0.1
percent increase in November a bit
higher many many economists thought it
was going to go down by 0.2 so maybe
we're not in recession and if you
compare the kind of part of where the
economy is with what economists have
forecast was recently this is the level
of GDP so the higher it is the Richer
the total sum of GDP is not that long
ago the bank of England thought it was
going to go down and down and down
similar story from the obr although they
thought we'd kind of have a bit of a ski
jump later on but nonetheless going down
here's what's actually happened so the
latest data suggests well look that dark
blue line is slightly above those dotted
lines so we're doing a little bit better
but some would say we're basically in
line we're just kind of bouncing around
so we're going to have to see in the
next few months but if you look at the
kind of breakdown of GDP one certainly
thing one thing is certainly striking
look at this this is services so the
services sector 80 of the economy
whether it's Financial Services whether
it's legal services retail that is
growing right now but look at
manufacturing of course higher energy
prices mean less in the way of
manufacturing particularly those high
energy parts of manufacturing so a
Divergence there one final thing I want
to point out because it is another bit
of good news here interest rate
expectations good news if you've got a
mortgage in particular do you remember
after the mini budget a lot of people
thought they were get up to above six
percent that came down to around four
point seven five percent by the end of
last year well look what it is the
latest number now it's down to four
point three eight percent maybe down to
four and a quarter percent quite soon so
it may be that the interest rates Spike
coming up in the next few months might
not be quite as high as many people had
expected